All right. It is time, so I'm going to go ahead and get us rolling.
I want to welcome everyone to the Chromatin Epigenetics and Cancer
session.
Historically, much of the focus of mechanistic
studies around cancer really focused on chromosomal instability and
DNA damage. And that seemed like a perfectly obvious thing
to think about. If you look under the microscope, chromosome number is
abnormal in cancer. They're often a bit scrambled.
And on top of that, things that cause nonspecific DNA damage, like radiation,
cause cancer. So it made perfect sense
to study that and sort of, voila, that is the
nature of cancer.
But there were also some things that were a bit surprising
about that. For instance, if one looks at genetically engineered mouse models, the
fastest way to get cancer in a mouse is not by inactivation of the DNA
repair pathways. It's by driving a transcription factor at
high levels, or as you'll see,
mutation of chromatin regulators.
And then if one looks at the genomes of cancers,
it's interesting. When there is a signature chromosomal translocation that
activates a transcription factor, the genomes of those cancers are
often quite simple
compared to those that don't have that signature transcription driving event.
And in fact, not only are the instability not
needed, it actually emerges that it can become a detriment to the
onset of cancer. And then as cancer genomes were really sequenced
and being looked at, very frequent
alterations of chromatin complexes,
essentially called epigenetic regulators,
emerge. And so one now begins to see
a mechanism whereby that instability may, in many
cases, just be sort of rolling the dice until you
can get alteration of transcription factors,
chromatin regulation, or signaling pathways in some cases.
And so then study of these mechanisms
becomes of great interest. What really is happening?
How are these things altering
the landscape to drive cancer? And might
insights into this actually be therapeutically actionable and useful?
And so as this field has advanced, the answers to both of those things
have turned out to be a resounding yes, in as much as we can find
out fantastic insights to the fundamental mechanisms that underlie
cancer, and it's now beginning to turn out that indeed, at least in
some cases, these are therapeutically actionable.
So,
great speakers who are joining me today on this topic,
and we're going to kick it off with a talk from Dr.
Liling Wang, who's going to talk about chromatin-associated
condensates. Liling.
Do I have a pointer?
Just the mouse.
Oh, just the mouse. Okay.
All right. First, I would like to thank Charlie for the nice
introduction of the few. And it's a great honor to be able to
present our work alongside leaders in the field, including Scott Armstrong
and Charlie Roberts. So today, I'm going to talk about chromatin
associate condensates, and hopefully, at the end of the talk, I can convince
you that these aberrant assemblies are a
real driver of cancer.
All right. So let's see.
So as we all appreciate that the identity of a normal cell is
largely dictated by its transcription program.
So when this program goes wrong, it oftentimes gives rise to disease states,
most notably the cancers. So in our lab, we're very
interested in understanding the basic chromatin mechanisms that underlie
gene regulation and how does dysregulation of those mechanisms
lead to cancer development and progression.
And ultimately, we're also very interested in leverage those
basic mechanistic understanding to thinking about therapeutic
discovery.
So, as I mentioned,
one of the mechanisms that our labs and others in the past few years has
really
studying is this concept that aberrant chromatin associate
condensate are emerging drivers of cancers.
And I will share with you some of our ongoing works as well as some published work
surrounding this topic.
So first, I want to introduce what is condensate.
In the past few years, there's numerous study has demonstrated that
proteins involved in gene regulation, in particular RNA
polymerase II, specific co-activators, and certain
transcription factors, they can display punctate structures in
cells. And in many cases, those assemblies are formed through not
only the lock and key interactions that many of us study over
the decades, but also the multivalent weak interactions that
oftentimes nonstop geometry, but also involve a
density transition.
So there's outstanding question in the field, in particular, what is the molecular
basis underlying those condensate formation?
Whether they really play a causal role in gene activation or
repression? And if they are very important in normal development and
physiology, oftentimes we're thinking about very likely cancer
is going to hijack those mechanisms, and can we actually thinking about
therapeutic potential targeting those assembly.
So what I wanted to share with you today, it's one of the
pretty striking example how mutations in these chromatin
regulators named ENL, which is a reader protein I will introduce
a little bit, can drive the formation of aberrant condensate and
those condensate very likely to be causal to the disease.
So ENL protein is a chromatin reader.
It binds to specific histone acetylation on H3
through its YEATS domain. It also had a EH domain,
which is very well characterized to interact with numerous chromatin
associate
complexes that involve in either histone modifications and also
active Pol II elongation.So the function
of ENL in cancer has really been quite remarkable
through very different mechanisms.
First, before realizing it's a reader protein,
experts in the leukemia field have identified ENL as one of the most
frequent fusion partners with the ML1 gene, and the resultant
ML fusion oncoproteins can drive very potent
leukemogenesis, in particular in pediatric patients.
So during my postdoc work under mentorship with Dr.
Allis and also Almsjo, we have identified the
wild-type copy of ENL is also very important.
Specifically, it functions as a chromatin reader.
It can bind to histone acetylation, as I mentioned.
This plays a very important role to stabilize associate super
elongation complex to maintain the active transcription
of key oncogenes that are very important for leukemia to make
genesis and maintenance. And quite excitingly,
our group has developed specific inhibitors that can block
the binding of ENL YAS domain with a set of histones and
demonstrate that these specific interactions can have
efficacy and molecular-defined leukemia in preclinical
models. And very excitingly,
a different version of this compound is now entering clinical
testing, and there's also numerous ENL degraders and
inhibitors under active development.
So hopefully we will see something progressing towards
clinical
applications in the future.
So the third mechanism of how ENL is involved in mutagenesis,
there's a series of oncogenic mutations that occurs in its
YAS domain, most frequently in pediatric
kidney cancer, Wilms' tumor, and also small subset of AML.
Now I will show you how those hotspot mutations actually drive a
gain of function in acquiring those condensates.
So we have been using an ENL gain-of-function mutation in the past few years,
really trying to understand how does pathogenic condensate
form, what is the function on chromatin, do they actually play a role
in pathogenesis, and can we really target those assembly?
And towards the second half of my talk, I'm also going to share with you
unpublished work surrounding how we are thinking about those condensates are
being regulated, in particular by nascent RNA transcript.
So first, I wanted to show you how those condensates are actually
formed and what's their function.
So before that, I wanted to show you briefly what those mutations look like.
On the left, you're seeing the sequence
zoom in of wild type in the bottom, and there are eight different
mutations identified so far clustered into either
small insertions or small deletions.
All those mutations cluster in regions.
On the right, I'm showing the crystal structure of wild-type ENL, where the
mutated regions are actually distant on the opposite side of the
acetylation binding pockets that I mentioned earlier.
So it wasn't very clear at the time what those mutations would do to
this protein.
Okay, so.
And what we end up finding is very interesting, that compared with
wild-type protein, which is homogeneously distributed in
the nucleus, where all the eight mutants I showed you form this
large descriptive condensate at physiologically relevant
expression. So, something I wanted to highlight is that when you're
thinking about transcription condensate in the literature, a lot of them
emphasize on the dynamic features.
But I wanted to highlight there's very distinct features
of this pathogenic condensate. First, they are very large,
very distinct, highly concentrated, as you can appreciate from this
imaging. And, in contrast of the dynamic behavior,
they actually have very low internal dynamics, and also
they are stably associated with selective targeting.
We can
actually image this for live cell imaging for over 10
hours, and they still associate with the targeting, which is quite remarkable.
And I will show you next slides that the association with this
condensate seems to drive the hyperactivation of their target gene.
So one of the target genes that
this condensate associate with this HOXA locus, which will turn out to be super
important for leukemia and Wilms' tumor that I will show you later.
But first, by looking at nascent RNA FISH, you can see
those condensates localized very nicely with the
transcribed site, and this is corresponding to gene
activation. Now, of course, you wanted to ask, is that causal or this
is just association? To address that question, we have done
extensive structural and biochemical analysis, which is published, so I'm
not going to mention. But over 20 different mutagenesis
assays that separate distinct function of this ENL protein,
we're able to establish a very strong correlation that cancer
mutation drive condensate formation from a targeting drive gene
activation. Now, different way of manipulating those
condensate, either complete abolish condensate, reducing their
size or reducing their number, can lead to corresponding
downregulation of gene expression.
Establishing a pretty
strong evidence that those condensate very likely to corresponding to gene
activation. Now, in the interest of time, I'm not going to go to details,
but what we think is happening is that those condensates enrich
very high local concentration of machinery that drive active
transcription elongation. And this turned out to
impact the frequency of transcription of bursting, which
is a bottleneck of gene expression that
across many
sites. So this eventually make a very rare
transcription events frequent and therefore allow the
transcription to reach a very high level that exceeding the
normal physiological
condition.Now, I wanted to show you a
little bit about whether those mutations actually function as
a driver of cancer, and if yes, whether they function through
a condensate-dependent manner. So to address this question, we
generate a condition knockout mouse model, putting this mutation in a
heterozygous manner in either the leukemia system, blood
system, or the kidney system. I'm just going to show you in
the leukemia context, heterozygous knocking of this
mutation drive full-blown leukemia in 100% of mice with very
short latency. And we validate that this is
very aggressive AML through transplantation, et cetera, analysis.
Now, how does this mutation actually drive leukemogenesis at the
cellular level? For those of you not familiar with leukemia or
blood development, this is showing you that in normal hematopoiesis
on the left, the stem cell give rise to myeloid
progenitor cells and eventually give rise to functional
differentiated myeloid cells. Whereas in the cancer mutant cases,
while the stem cells remain similar number, we
observe
expansion of numerous cluster of the
aberrant progenitor population, which actually displayed
a spectrum of differentiation phenotypes.
And those population eventually outgrow, and I think this lead
to the lethality in the mice.
So what is the molecular mechanism underlying this?
We went on to profile every single one of this population and
identify overwhelmingly a pathway that involve in development,
but also inflammation. But for the interest of time,
I'm going to zoom in into one of the most upregulated and critical
oncogenes that those mutation regulated, which is the
HOXA locus. So the HOXA, it's very critical
for normal hematopoiesis because it's important for cell renewal of the stem
cells. As cells differentiated, the HOX genes undergo
silencing by polycomb complexes.
Now, in the context of mutant, I hope you can appreciate the scale bar here
that those mutant cells in the stem cell have
much higher expression level, but those level maintained throughout the
whole differentiation cascade, very likely suggesting that
there is not only active transcription happening, but also
suppression of the polycomb silencing.
So how does it work? Is it related to condensate?
First, I'm showing you, this is a very busy slide, but just to
orient you, I'm showing you four different population from stem cell all the way to
differentiated cells. And,
normally, this is highly acetylated.
You won't really see it because of the scale bar, but
the polycomb-mediated H3K27 will
increase over time to silencing this region as cell differentiate.
Now, in the context of mutant, not only the acetylation is highly
gained in stem cell, but look at all the progenitor cells that are
actually
propagated in those mutant mice. They have extremely high level of
acetylation
on the target genes, very likely as due to the massive
recruitment of P300, which is a writer of the
H3K27 acetyl. And we think that perhaps,
this stable association of condensate at the site
also provide a physical barrier to
prevent polycomb from coming and remodel those sites, which
is something that awaits further investigation.
Now,
is the condensate really driving this phenotype?
We've again leveraged mutagenesis assays and looking
at various of mutants that disrupt the condensate or retain the condensate,
and are really showing that it is the condensate are really driving this kind of
chromatin remodeling. And I wanted to propose this
idea that perhaps a condensate function as a read-write
feedback loop, which binds to acetylation,
forms a condensate, recruit more P300, further write
acetylation, therefore reinforce this locus as an aberrant on
state and perhaps also physically blocking polycomb from coming
and silencing those region. So I think that through both
biochemical, structural, and also cellular and in vivo study, we
really establish ENL mutation and their condensate
as a potent driver of cancer.
Now, if they're really important, can we target those condensate
using the informations or insights that we have gained?
So one thing I wanted to point out is that those mutation occurs in a
region that is distant from the histone acetylation binding.
And it turns out that those mutant also rely on their
histone acetylation binding to actually go to their target genes.
In other words, this open up the possibility that if we can
target in the histone acetylation, maybe this will disrupt the condensate
behavior. So is that really the case?
Here again, I'm showing you some schematic that if we treat the cells having
those condensates sitting on the target genes,
with this inhibitor with very short time, we can see that the
condensate actually still there lingering around, which is kind of interesting.
But importantly, they are no longer at their target genes.
And a consequence of that is that this reverse the transcription activation
drive by those mutation quite significantly.
And even more impressive, I think this data is very exciting, is that several weeks
of treatment, once a day with this inhibitor in a very
aggressive established leukemias model, can leads to over five
months of survival extension, suggesting that
this leukemia is still require ENL
mutation for sustaining their malignant
state.So with that, in the
rest of the five minutes or so, I'm going to share with you this
idea or this question that how are those pathogenic
condensates being regulated? Our lab has currently
conducted a target approach, but also on a buyer's screening approach.
And for today, I want to show you how we're thinking about
the local nascent transcript produced from the target
sites can actually regulate the condensate nucleation.
So why RNA? RNA is known to play important roles
in numerous biomolecular condensate, including nuclear speckles,
nucleoli, stress granule, et cetera.
Now, in the context of transcription,
the Young lab has proposed this model where at the beginning
of, at the initiation of a transcription, the low level of
RNA actually play a positive role to promote the condensate
formation. And as the transcription goes on, there's more and more
RNA and longer RNA, this lead to a charge imbalance, and
therefore promote the dissolution of the condensate.
And this is a very nice concept to perhaps explain
why the transcription is maintained in the optimal levels that
is needed for normal development and physiology condition.
Now, with this concept in mind, when we're looking at this ENL condensate, two
things really puzzle us. First, is that this locus has extremely
high expression level. There's a lot of RNA in those condensate.
Yet those condensate are super stable.
They can last for over 10 hours, which indicating that they
must have a way to actually overcome the RNA mediated
inactive feedback.
So we decided to looking at the role of RNA in ENL
mutants. So in this cases, we conducted
structural modeling with Haitao Li's group at Tsinghua
University, identify a specific patch regions that
very likely to engage with RNA.
And importantly, we show by purify protein assays,
the EMSA assay that the ENL mutant binds to RNA,
and the 3A mutant, which is a charge
neutralizing mutants, 3A mutants, can partially
reduce the RNA binding. And I want you to keep this in mind that the partial
reductions turn out to be very important point later.
Consistently, in cell assay, CLAT assay shows that this
RNA binding is also reduced partially in cells.
Does it matter for the condensate formation? The answer is yes.
So here you're looking at incubation of ENL and RNA protein
together, ENL protein and RNA together.
The RNA actually increase the condensate formation by ENL
mutant. And again, the 3A mutant has a similar base
level of condensate formation, but their response to RNA
enhanced droplet formation is reduced.
So as this matters in cells, I shown you that ENL mutant
forms about seven-ish or seven to 10
condensate in the cells across different cell lines.
And now if we're looking at what is the difference between the cancer
mutant versus 3A mutant, they still form condensate, but this
leads to partial reduction of condensate numbers across different
cell lines. Now with fewer number of condensate, we can
also quantify that there's a fewer frequency of HOXA
locus that actually cover by a ENL condensate.
And this has a real consequence because then this leads to
reduced frequency of transcriptional bursting shown by the nascent
RNA FISH analysis here,
that the mutant increase frequency of
transcription bursting, whereas the 3A largely reverse that
phenotype.
So this suggesting that the number of condensate
forms at a target gene matters for its transcription.
Now by reducing the RNA binding, this reduce the transcription of
bursting and therefore reduce the transcription level.
If this is the case, we ask, can we testing this hypothesis
through a different way? Can we block the RNA synthesis and
visualize the impact of the condensate nucleation at
endogenous target genes, which has never been done before.
So how do we do that? First, I want to show you the system.
I already demonstrated that ENL condensate sit on a target gene.
Here we quantify a HOX locus, 95% of HOX locus
will have a ENL condensate sitting on them.
Now, if we treat the cells with its inhibitors, it leads to
a reduce of the frequency because it displays the condensate from
target sites.
And we can wash off this inhibitor over time, and you can actually see that
those condensate reform at the target site by this
quantification here, allowing a dynamic system for us
to asking what happen if we do this at the same time of
transcription inhibition. And sure enough, this actually leads to a quite
profound defect in nucleating at a target gene,
suggesting that the basal
transcription level is really important for this phenotype.
So does this really matters for tumorigenesis?
We leverage a system that we demonstrate before, taking out a stem
cell transduced with various of ENL mutants.
Again, the cancer mutant form condensate, in particular the HOX
locus as well, and 3A partially reduce the condensate formation.
And remarkably, even though this is a partial reduction in
condensate formation transcription, this almost lead to
complete abolish of tumorigenesis, suggesting to
us that tumorigenesis is not a linear process.
Instead, there is a threshold that the cancer cells need to
reach for the oncogenic expression in order for the malignant
transformation to occur.With that, I wanted to just to summarize, we
have demonstrated, identified our surface and the ENL yeast domain
engage with RNA, and this basal RNA interaction with
ENL lower the threshold of condensate nucleation in target sites
leads to frequent transcription bursting that allowed
enough transcription activation to drive potent tumor genesis.
Even partial reduction of RNA binding can lead to
a meaningful reduction in transcription bursting that
ultimately impair tumor genesis.
I also wanted to put out this concept that perhaps different from
normal condensate that
subject to RNA media inactive feedback, pathogenic condensate
illustrate by ENL example here that could co-opt
RNA as a positive regulators to actually
reinforce condensate nucleation and therefore,
reaching a high enough oncogenic expression.
So with that, I'm just going to summarize that hopefully I convince you by
studying this series of mutation, we demonstrate that condensate
dysregulation can really function as a driver of cancer,
in this case, by driving persistent oncogenic activation.
I'm not going into all the key insights, but what I wanted to land with
is that very likely, many of those insights we gain from
studying ENL mutations could apply to many other
examples to other and a few has demonstrated forming
condensate. Okay, I think my time is up.
I wanted to just end it by thanking the people involved in this work.
I already highlight the works I've shown you really initiated by
four remarkable trainees in lab, Luolo Song, Krista,
Iman, Qinglan, and Chujie, and also this is supported
by our wonderful collaborator, in particular Haitao Li's group
at Tsinghua University. And, of course, our funding. And thank you very much.
I hope I have time for some questions.
Okay, there are microphones at the front of
both aisles there.
Thanks. Great talk.
Thank you.
You didn't describe how
ENL knows which transcript to go to.
So-
Right
... where does the specificity for HOXA11 come from and-
... are there any hnRNP proteins
that are binding the nascent transcripts that are involved in this?
This is a great question. This is a question regarding the target
specificity. I have to say that we don't have a full answer.
We know the locus is very large. It has a lot of acetylation,
but that doesn't explain the high specificity.
I wanted to point out that something we're currently doing is if we put this ENL
mutant into different cell line system, it's not always HOX.
So they actually go to very different target sites.
So we're in a process of trying to understand what is a common feature of those
target sites to come up with an answer.
In terms of whether
there are other RNA binding proteins in there.
So,
the challenge in a few is to really identify condensate-specific
proteomics, and this is something that we are actively working
on, trying to understand what's in there. Howard.
Hey, Luling. Thank you for the nice talk.
Thank you.
So you showed an experiment arguing that RNA is important for the
condensate formation with the actinomycin D.
But by blocking transcription, there are transcription-associated
processes like-
Yes
... Pol II and basically the writing of the
H3K27 acetylation.
Exactly.
It doesn't really directly pin it to the RNA product.
Right. Yeah.
Can you actually use an antisense oligo or something to deplete the specific
RNA? Now, I understand that there's a huge number of long non-coding RNAs and
coding transcripts in that locus. Maybe that's not possible.
Maybe you can tell us about the-
That's a great question. That's a Reviewer 3 question.
Yummy.
So,
we did have that concern. We actually tried really hard to do a locus-specific
targeting.
The challenge is that because the HOX locus has over 10
genes, so we tried to target a few, but there's still so much
RNA in there, so we barely see much phenotype.
Another thing I wanted to say that ongoing work has actually shown is
that within the condensate, there's not just HOX, there's actually 3D genome
organizations, so multiple target genes to make it the target specific.
So I fully acknowledge that the use of transcription inhibitor could have
other impact. I think this is exactly why we wanted to use
the mutation in the ENL, as well as the
transcription inhibition together, and they actually converge into very similar
phenotype. But I think that there's other things in
the transcription machinery very likely engage with that
charge patch to identify as well. But that's a great point.
Great. One final question over here.
Hi. Thank you for a nice talk. So just have a question for the 3A.
You show that the 3A variant decrease the condensate formation ability.
I just wondering if you have any investigations to show that
it is mediated by that
three specific positive charged amino acids, or just because of
the decreased less positive charge. Thank you.
Well, to your question, there is actually...
I guess those question are integrated, right?
So it's either the number of charge or that specific charge.
Our structural modelings
inform that RNA seems to most likely engage with that
particular region, but it's also a very large region.
So we chose the 3A residues because we
wanted to minimally impact other known function of ENL so that we
can isolate RNA binding effect, but that's a good point.
All right.
Okay. I said the last question, but let's do one more over here.
Thank you. Excellent talk. Thank you. I learned a lot.
My question is,
using the inhibitor or the mutation of ENL,
it also, in fact, that the function is
the proteinperceive? How we can
explain it is the condensates change
per se is not the related abundance or
the protein function itself.
Right. That's a good question. In these cases,
the compound is not designed
to dissolve the condensate specifically.
I think this is really based on our extensive work to
demonstrate a condensate formation at HOX string is very important.
So this small molecule inhibitor is basically trying to say, "Okay, if that
structure is important, if we can displace that structure, does it
have a consequence?" So
I acknowledge the specific inhibitor is not designed to
dissolve the condensate, but this actually demonstrate that
beyond dissolving condensate, there's other way to target condensate as
well, such as making them coming off the chromatin. Thank you.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Thanks, Liling. Just a really fantastic mechanistic discussion, and I
think really illustrates how the field is advancing.
With that, we want to transition to a true pioneer in the
field of generating insight into how chromatin
alterations are driving cancer,
and now being able to successfully therapeutically intervene.
So Dr. Scott Armstrong from Dana-Farber Cancer Institute.
Thanks, Charlie, for the introduction and the invitation.
It's really great to be on the stage with someone who we started our labs
basically at the same time together at Dana-Farber, and also with somebody
who spent 20 to 30% of her time anyway as a postdoctoral fellow in my lab.
Spent most of her time learning biochemistry from the late David Allis, but in so
doing, led an incredible collaboration between our labs. So thank you, Liling.
So as Charlie mentioned, I'm going to talk a little bit more about the therapeutic
side
of some of the mechanisms that Liling just talked about.
And in fact, her mechanistic talk is a great
background for the MLL fusions because everything she just said about
ENL is probably how the MLL fusions work as well.
So that's tremendous
background for the talk. So these are the people that have done the work.
These are my disclosures. The only one that's relevant is menin inhibition in
NPM1 mutant AML because I'm going to talk quite a bit about that.
So you've heard
a little bit from Liling about the MLL fusions.
MLL fusion proteins schematically shown here are generated by
translocations of the MLL or KMT2A gene.
Those are used interchangeably.
And when that translocation occurs, it
generates an MLL fusion protein shown here, where the N-terminus of wild-type
MLL is fused to the C-terminus of actually what's some 100
different fusion proteins. But ENL, as Liling said, is one of the common ones,
AF9 as well, AF4. All of those are members of different
chromatin-associated complexes themselves.
And the presence of this translocation in leukemia is
associated with a particularly poor prognosis.
That's what got me into it when I learned that in the late '90s.
The clinical part was discovered in the '80s, and then the
breakpoint was cloned by a number of groups in the early '90s to
show that this MLL protein, the wild-type version of
which is a 500 kilodalton nuclear protein, was the
homolog of Drosophila Trithorax.
Really through this C-terminal SET domain, which we now know based on David
Allis's work, is a histone H3 lysine 4
methyltransferase that regulates both in Drosophila
and in mammalian cells, the HOX genes or homeotic genes that you heard about
from Liling, and in leukemia, particularly the HOXA cluster genes.
Dave's lab isolated this large MLL complex shown here,
and a number of groups showed that the MLL wild-type protein
is cleaved into an N-terminus and C-terminus.
And suffice it to say that the MLL fusion basically is this N-terminal
part fused to the C-terminus of many different proteins, and
therefore you lock together a group of chromatin
complexes that should not be locked together that way in order to drive gene
expression. In early 2000s as well, Mike Cleary
and Matthew Meyerson independently demonstrated that
this protein here, menin, the product of the multiple endocrine neoplasia type
1 gene, is found both in the wild-type MLL
complex, that was Matthew Meyerson's work, and the ONC
protein complex,
Mike Cleary's work. And then in the early 2010s, Jolanta Grimbecka showed
that actually you could make small molecules that could disrupt
this interaction.
And while we were working on the biology of MLL fusions, which I won't talk about
at all really today other than in the context of menin inhibitors, we started a
collaboration in 2014 with which
then was called Vitae Pharmaceuticals with Gerry McGeehan,
and then he moved to Syndax Pharmaceuticals.
And in the process,
they identified a very potent and selective small molecule menin
inhibitor. And we showed mechanistically how that works is by
disrupting the MLL menin interaction. That actually was known.
That was what it was supposed to do.
But when it does that, the MLL fusion actually comes off of chromatin at
very selected loci. Getting back a little bit to the discussion about loci
selectivity and how that works, continuing to work on that.
But certain MLL fusion loci and wild-type MLL
loci are very dependent on menin to remain bound to chromatin, and it's
those genes that get repressed whenever you treat with an MLL
menin inhibitor.
Here's the VTB-50469 we published in 2019.
You move one methyl group and you have what is now called revumenib.
And while doing this, we also were able to show that both in
NPM1 mutant AMLs, which many of you probably know are way more common than
MLL fusion rearranged AMLs, and in a rare
but deadly subtype of pediatric AML, those with nucleoporin
98 rearrangements, very similar mechanisms are at play.
The mutant nucleophosmin actually binds toHOX loci,
MEIS1,
after it's mutated, and it's dependent on MLL menin interaction in
order to maintain that expression, and essentially the NUP98 fusion
works very similarly. And with these three mutations, this accounts for
about 40% of all AML cases in both adults and
children. And perhaps the most exciting part of this in the past
year and a half or two years, the FDA has approved revumenib for the
treatment of relapsed/refractory KMT2A rearranged
AML and NPM1 AML in
2024 and 2025 respectively, and ziftomenib from
Cure Oncology for NPM1 mutant AML also in
2025. So these now are definitely being given to patients,
at least in the United States. Hopefully approvals to follow soon in other
parts of the country. But as you might imagine, with any single-agent
targeted therapy, there's always the possibility of the development of
resistance. Having said that, this was at least one of the first, if not
the first protein-protein interaction inhibitor that was targeting
chromatin, so we didn't really know exactly what to expect in terms of how
the cells would mutate themselves, adapt, in order to
become what we presumed would be resistant to the small molecule.
So the first type of mutational resistance we described, I'm going to go through
quickly because this is published, so I can get into the other stuff.
But basically using base editor screens, PDX models,
and samples from patients that were sequenced at Memorial
Sloan Kettering, we were able to show that indeed,
mutation of the small molecule binding pocket is a very common
form of resistant to single-agent therapy.
These are the mutations that we've described as the most common.
We definitely are seeing these now in patients with some
frequency, and this methionine 327 being the one that
affects most of the inhibitors. There are actually now some five or six
being developed,
and this G331 also being particularly difficult to deal with.
All of the mutations shift the IC50s for the small molecule and
affect the affinities of the small molecules for their binding.
These mutations are found in patients with MLL rearranged and NPM1
mutant AML. That's important because, as I said, it wasn't so clear, at least
at the time, if the NPM1 mutant AML was being
driven by menin.
And interestingly enough, we published soon a paper
showing the full landscape of mutations that can lead to
resistance to the five different clinical inhibitors, and as you might
imagine from a structural standpoint, the mutations are not all the same, and you
can actually get one to work in the context of the
mutation
that was generated in the presence
of one of the other inhibitors. Sorry.
So of course, combination therapies are one way
to deal with this, but the important from a biological standpoint
here is that this really does validate menin as a therapeutic target when
the cancers go to this amount of trouble to mutate themselves.
However, I've told you that
the way that this resistance develops, it's not an absolute resistance.
You just shift the IC50 anywhere between five and tenfold,
sometimes even less than that, when you develop these mutations.
So Wallace Bourgeois in the lab wanted to ask the question as to whether or not
if you increase the dose in mice in a PDX experiment, how
would that affect the development of these mutations?
So this is a very large, as you can see, PDX experiment.
Each one of these lines is a mouse measuring the amount of human
leukemia cells in the peripheral blood of the mice.
And the mice were treated with chow that had three different concentrations of
revumenib, 0.03%, 0.1%, and
0.3%. And we know that the 0.1% is the dose that gives us
a very similar exposure in mice to what people are
getting in the early-phase trials.
And you can see those in purple. Essentially every one of these mice had a
response, went into what you might call something like a remission in a mouse, and
then ultimately developed very aggressive resistance.
And in 17 of the 20 cases, those leukemias had the
mutations that we had seen in patients.
Interestingly enough, if you go up by threefold on the dose, one, you
really extend the survival of the mice, and now the mutational form of
resistance actually doesn't appear to be the most common form of resistance.
And in fact, you get some type of low-grade persistent state, that
the cells somehow have adapted to maintain themselves in that state.
I'm not going to talk much more about that. That's much harder to study.
We are studying it, but still don't quite understand what's going on there.
But in three of the mice here that looked like they had the kinetics of
resistance that was identical, if you will, to the
mutational binding pocket form, had wild-type
menin. So obviously what we did then was just sequence the genomes
or the exomes of those samples, and in fact, in two out of
three of them,
one of the leukemias had a 50% VAF
heterozygous
lysine 123 to valine mutation on MLL,
the oncoprotein itself that obviously is binding to menin.
And the other one, a protein called LEDGF, which is the third component of
this complex. I didn't mention it earlier, but MLL, menin, and LEDGF
interact with each other. I'll show you the structure of that in a minute.
And that was one of the other mutations.
So the leukemias are mutating the other
proteins in the protein-protein interaction, not
the one where the inhibitor is binding.
We were asked by a reviewer if this happens for more
than one of the inhibitors, so that was nice
inasmuch as it gave us the motivation to do this experiment where we now can't put
it in the chow. We actually have to
dose these mice daily with the Janssen
molecule, blexominib, and in fact, we see a similar phenomenon.
Higher concentration works a little better, and now we're seeing actually with
the blexominib, maybe even slightly-more frequent
development of these KMT2A mutations.
And now these mutations are actually slightly different in terms of where they are,
and I'll get into that in just a minute.
So it's possible that the frequency of these types of mutations may vary
from one
inhibitor to the other.
So let me get a little bit of detail into the structure here.
This is a structure of minin. This is most of minin here,
a bit of Ledgef, and just the very N-terminus of MLL here in
purple wrapping around minin. And this is the binding site where the minin
inhibitor binds, and these are the mutations that affect directly the minin
inhibitor
affinities and therefore shift the IC50s.
The mutations we're seeing in KMT2A, we've actually seen a number of them now.
I've mentioned G123V and the G137 that I'll talk about in
a minute, are on this side of MLL, and in fact, here, this amino
acid appears to be directing itself toward minin, and
the G137 that I'm going to tell you about in a minute, actually, the mutation
directs itself towards Ledgef. And if
you model these by AlphaFold, it looks like those mutations are leading
to hydrogen bonds, potentially, that therefore might increase the
affinity of MLL for either minin or Ledgef.
So the concept arises that probably what's happening is you have
multivalent protein-protein interactions here, and in the wild-type setting,
this one is the critical interaction, but whenever you put enough pressure on the
leukemia, it'll develop these mutations in these other parts that
will then stabilize the complex.
So if that's the case, it would presumably be the case that these
would lead to resistance in the presence of all of the different minin inhibitors,
and we've now studied that in quite some detail.
I'll summarize most of it, but the way you do this, as you might imagine, is
to do CRISPR
editing to introduce the mutation of interest, and we did this first
for the KMT2AG123 mutation.
And here, this is the wild type, and these are the IC50s for the
J&J molecule, the
Gleximinib, Ziftominib, and Revuminib, and you can see that in the presence of
this G123V, you actually shift somewhere between nine and
15-fold the IC50 for proliferation.
So indeed, these mutations do induce resistance to the
inhibitors in cell lines. They prevent the changes in
gene expression that we know that the minin inhibitors do. That's shown here.
So this is wild type. Here's one of the binding mutants, and here's the
KMT2AG123V, and you see we've really
suppressed the changes in gene expression.
These labeled genes on the left are the ones we know tend to change in the
presence of the minin inhibitor. Here's what's happening on chromatin.
So this is ChIP-seq for minin at the MEIS1 locus or the HOXA cluster.
We've characterized multiple times that when you treat with a minin inhibitor,
minin, at least by ChIP-seq, is essentially gone from chromatin.
And at the loci where the gene expression will be suppressed, like
MEIS1, you lose MLL as well. And you can see
here in the presence of the G123V, we no longer get the
MLL fusion off of chromatin. We no longer get repression of gene
expression, and similar types of things happening at the HOXA
cluster.
So that's supportive of the concept that
the mutations are stabilizing this complex
such that minin inhibitors are no longer able to work.
And another piece of evidence is shown here.
I'm going to go through this in some detail because it's a little bit complicated.
But this is the G137D mutation that's right
somewhere in here.
It really pointing at Ledgef and predicted to
generate a hydrogen bond here between MLL and
Ledgef, probably other chemical changes as well.
And
what Reina Takeda in the lab has done is overexpressed either a
wild-type MLL fusion or an MLL fusion with this
G137 mutation in 293
cells and then just did an IP and looked, does minin come down with it?
Does Ledgef come down with it? And what happens if you mutate Ledgef?
Because the hypothesis is perhaps Ledgef is now acting as a
bridge
since MLL has mutated itself to hang on to Ledgef potentially
with a greater affinity. So this is the wild type setting.
You treat with the minin inhibitor.
You lose minin interaction with the MLL fusion.
It doesn't matter if you have Ledgef or not.
That interaction is stable, and you treat with the minin inhibitor,
you disrupt it.
However, when you
mutate the MLL fusion,
now the small molecule doesn't disrupt the MLL
minin interaction, and if you remove Ledgef, it does.
So what that is suggesting that basically this mutation has
made Ledgef a potent bridge in the complex that
allows the fusion to remain
bound. So supporting the concept that basically these mutations
stabilize this complex. However, they can make themselves mutate in
order to prevent the protein-protein interaction inhibitor from disrupting the
complex.
I'm not going to go through this in too much detail, but to say that we've now done
base editor screening across the length of the N-terminal part
anyway of the MLL coding region, and these are the
various domains in the N-terminus of MLL that are known to bind to minin.
This is the domain that actually binds to the site where the small molecule is
binding.
The most interesting and most common mutations that we're seeing are in
these so-called integrase binding motifs.
That's the part that wraps around Ledgef.
I also want to show this because I just find the power of these base editing
screens so incredible. So you probably know how this works, but
you basically make a library of guides that are predicted to
mutate the vast majority of the amino acids across this region.
We put the minin inhibitor on and just ask which guides are selected for.
And it's really remarkable that just these domains here that interact with
minin are the ones that are being selected for, and the regions out here and in
these AT-hooks that would probably have a different function don't seem to score.
SoInterestingly, also, these
mutations that are clustering here essentially all lead to these three
mutations: S119L, G123V, which I've already talked about,
and G141S. But I think you're starting to get the flavor that
basically this alpha helix here that's sitting right next to both menin and
LEDGF is a site where the leukemia is really going to some
trouble to mutate itself. So I've talked to you about binding pocket
mutations, complex stabilizing mutations.
I've alluded to the drug-tolerant persisters.
We haven't gotten into those yet,
but we're continuing to do biochemical work
on these so-called stabilizing mutants.
So in the last couple of minutes,
what are we going to do next? Well, of course, clinically, what's happening next is
the small molecule menin inhibitors are being combined with chemotherapy and other
agents in patients both upfront and the relapse refractory setting.
We'll see how these mutations play out in that context.
What we're interested in is can we develop rationally combined targeted
therapies that perhaps someday will allow us to not give
that chemotherapy? And we've done a number of experiments to try to figure out what
other complexes might be relevant.
And I'm not going to show any of this data because it's all published, but in
2022, we found that KAT6A and the menin-MLL
complex seem to be working together to maintain gene expression and
proliferation in the setting of gastrointestinal stromal tumors.
And we just reported the fact that something similar is going on
with an estrogen receptor-driven breast
cancer cell lines and other models.
I'm going to show you just a piece of that data in a minute.
And then working both with Charles Mulligan at St.
Jude and with Mark Dawson when he was at
Peter Mac in Australia, same thing in leukemia.
KAT6/7 acetylation, histone
acetyltransferases work together with menin to support this gene
expression, and particularly given Liling's just talk right now, that acetylation
should ring a bell to you because that acetyl mark probably is read
by ENL, and we know that ENL is in these complexes
as well. So
just one piece of data in breast cancer, just to talk about something other
than leukemia for a moment.
Naomi Olsen was-- As many of you probably know, Pfizer is developing a
KAT6A inhibitor. It's actually in Phase 3 clinical trials in
patients with ER-positive breast cancer.
With that in mind, we decided in the understanding that the
KAT6A and menin may be doing something together, we did a number of different types
of screens, and indeed, it looked like KAT6 and menin are working together in this
setting as well. So this is an experiment where we--
Many of you probably know this. You could just stimulate these cell lines with
estradiol, and that will lead to really dramatic changes in gene
expression. If we pre-treated with KAT6A inhibitor, we
suppressed those changes in gene expression, but did not
completely suppress them. With the menin inhibitor, we do the same.
It's probably even a little less good than the KAT6A inhibitor.
But when you combine both, we essentially prevented all the
estradiol-driven gene expression changes.
And the reason that's likely happening is shown here.
So this is RNA Pol II ChIP-seq.
This is control ChIP-seq at a number of loci, including the estrogen
receptor itself.
After treatment with the KAT6A inhibitor, the menin inhibitor in
green or the combination. And these are the
ER-responsive
loci, and these are control loci. I think you can pretty easily see
that in the combination, we lose Pol II
occupancy at the ER-associated
loci. So whatever this is doing is it's somehow
influencing estrogen receptor's ability.
Well, it influences estrogen receptor expression and probably its ability
to drive gene expression. So we're working more into the details.
Don't know exactly how this works.
I will not be surprised at all if it's working in the context of some condensate,
as Liling was talking about. And so we're continuing to work on that.
So
probably don't need to summarize too much other than to say that
MLL, a lot of excitement certainly in the leukemia field about menin
inhibitors.
Resistance is something that is going to probably have to be dealt with one
way or another. We're still certainly interested in looking for whether
or not these MLL mutations occur in
patients. But we think it's quite interesting, this
concept that protein-protein interaction inhibitors, one way that cells may get
around them is just by mutating multiple interfaces.
And of course, ultimately, hopefully, rational combinations targeting
multiple complexes, assuming toxicity is not a major issue, may
be a way that we can take further advantage of these approaches.
So I will stop there. Thank the people in my lab,
funders,
and take questions if there are any. Thanks.
Fantastic talk, Scott.
Microphones are open.
I have a question. The stabilizing
mutations, do the menin inhibitors still bind?
It's a good question.
And not a simple one to answer as of yet.
So we're in the process of generating, reconstituting the
complex and looking at that
more directly. I think that LEDGF
experiment is evidence that it's
probably... I don't know how a wild-type LEDGF would have some type
of allosteric effect and not allow the menin inhibitors to bind, because then we
take the LEDGF out, and they work even though the mutant
MLL is in there. So I think the answer is yes, but we have not been able
to directly show that.
Okay, so then you haven't done... Because the obvious experiment, so they bind, is
to make
a degrader
to see then if you degrade the complex, whether you overcome resistance to these-
Yes
... mutations.
That would be
certainly the next thought is the degradation of menin might be aWay to
get around this. That's exactly right.
If-
And then maybe one other question.
The mutations that arise rapidly versus the mutations
that arise maybe later, is there any evidence that this is a product
of, say, just
disease burden and heterogeneity?
Or is there some evidence that these are sort of acquired de novo mutations?
Yeah. So
we don't have as much understanding of those dynamics in
this second type of mutational setting.
With the minin inhibitor or the minin binding mutants where they
mutate the
binding site, it really seems to be just
how much it influences the binding of the inhibitor determines how
quickly they arise.
Oh, right. I see.
But in the setting of this type of mutation, we don't know the answer to that yet.
Thank you.
Question over here.
Thank- Thanks, Scott. Beautiful work.
So my question is, do we have an understanding of how frequent these
mutations drive resistance in the clinic?
Does it account for all resistance, or is there other mechanisms that we
don't quite understand yet?
Yeah, it certainly doesn't, in the clinic account, it doesn't
appear. Obviously, this is still kind of just getting information from all over
the world and accumulating it in your head.
I don't think anyone's actually looked at this, but it feels like that
it's very common, but it's certainly not the only type of single-agent
resistance. And also, as you probably know, there's
not every patient responds to a minin inhibitor.
It's a 30% to 40% response rate. And those mutations
are certainly not what's causing the resistance up front.
That's something, whatever it is, something completely different.
So I was going to ask that question.
So do you have any views at all as to what might be driving that innate resistance
or certainly acquired resistance that's not mutational?
So I think the acquired resistance is
at least 50% of it is mutational. So it's really a major
part in the single-agent setting.
I think this kind of persistent population that I was
talking about is giving us some hints as to what the other type of
resistance might be. But
as I'm sure you know, studying 3,000 cells that were generated
after a year on the drug is a really slow process to figure out, so
we just haven't been able to get to that yet.
Super. Thank you.
Okay. Thank you.
All right. So, final talk of this morning.
Here's disclosures.
So I want to begin with some background of the problem that first got me
interested in this field. I was working as a postdoc in Stu
Orkin's lab when there was reports in "Nature" from Olivier Delattre
that there were mutations in this gene that we now call
SMARCB1 or INI1 in the large majority of a very
aggressive cancer of childhood called malignant rhabdoid tumor that can
occur in kidney, brain, and soft tissues.
And this caught my attention
because I think history has shown us that genes that are mutated in the earliest
onset childhood cancers, and this affects babies and toddlers, can
often be a bit of a canary in a coal mine to alert us
to important principles in cancer.
And here I think about retinoblastoma, a rare pediatric cancer,
but fundamentally the disease that taught us about the importance of the RB
gene and pathway.
So at the time, we didn't know a whole lot about it other than it was part of a
chromatin remodeling complex. What I'm showing here in the
cartoons now, work from Tsgal Kadosh and others, giving a
structure of these complexes. We now know that the switch NIF
complex essentially forms a C clamp around
nucleosomes with SMARCB1 in two of the three families
being the docking site on the nucleosome that essentially enables these
complexes to remodel nucleosomes and mobilize them to activate
transcription.
So since that time, while the initial finding was in a rare cancer, it has
emerged that these mutations are remarkably frequent
in cancer,
accounting for 20% of all cancers now we know contain a mutation
in a subunit of switch NIF, also known as the BAF
complex. At least nine different subunits or genes that
encode subunits of the complex are recurrently mutated in
cancer. And interestingly, in addition to the 20% of
cancers, it's now emerging that there are a number of neurodevelopmental
disorders that have an inherited germline mutation in a
switch NIF subunit,
and so seeing real links between developmental disorders
and cancer.
So it then really emerged as a major tumor
suppressor complex, not originally recognized because of
complex nomenclature of all these different subunits, and then really became
clear that we're really talking about a single remodeling complex
here.
So my lab began utilizing then this rare
pediatric cancer as a model system, and we think of it
as a powerful system because it has remarkably
simple genomes. So the tumors are diploid.
When we sequenced the genomes, they tended to have a total of four base pair
mutations in the exome, one of which was always inactivating
SMARCB1, and the other three appeared to be random.
And so it could, in theory, be a cancer that's truly
driven by mutation of a single gene.
And so we then became interested in using this to
begin to understand what are the normal functions of the switch NIF
complexes.
Delattre's findings really caught people by surprise.
This was thought of almost like a Pol II complex, just fundamental to
transcription. Why the heck would you be getting mutations in something there to
drive cancer?At the same time, then what are the consequences
of the disease-associated mutations?
And if one thinks about this like a geneticist, those are really highly
linked questions. A geneticist would just simply take a normal
setting, mutate a gene, and find out what happens.
And here we're being informed by nature by all of these mutations, and what
do they do. And then importantly, can we use this information to
think about therapeutically intervening?
Just as background, some prior data from the lab as we began
looking what are these things doing in cells, we and others,
Segal and others, found that these complexes really
work at enhancers to facilitate
activation of lineage-specific gene expression.
And they're both present at enhancers and promoters, but as we
mutate SMARCB1, the dominant effects really happen at the
enhancers. The loss of K27 acetylation happens at
enhancers, but not much at promoters.
We went on, I won't show these other than the titles, because
we've published them a year or two ago, found roles that
also gave additional clues, we think, to why these complexes are
important in cell fate control. First, that two of the subunits, but not
the entire complex, is actually bind in mitosis and
act as mitotic bookmarks to enable cells to remember
their fate or increase the ability of cells to remember their fate
as they exit from mitosis. And it appears that as
they bind, then in G1, the whole complex comes and replaces
those or may be built in site. And
interestingly, a truly fascinating thing that we're
moving forward in drug space that I won't talk about today is the
finding of DCAF5 as a vulnerability.
And so it turns out that this is an E3 ligase that when
one of the subunits is missing, SMARCB1, the complex is then
degraded by DCAF5 to eliminate it.
And if you get rid of DCAF5, the complex
reassembles. It's still missing SMARCB1, but it has
between 30% and 70% wild type activity, which turns out
to be plenty of activity to actually reverse the cancer cell fate and send the
cells back down their normal differentiation pathways.
So,
fascinating mechanistic insight.
And so more broadly, the lab has been leveraging functional
genomics. The power of genomic screens in
yeast were so clear, Drosophila so clear in the '90s,
but has been much more challenging in the setting of mammalian
cells to think about how can we objectively look at the
landscape of interactors.
And might we be able to use forward genetic screens, functional
screens, to then think about therapeutic intervention?
And it was really the Cancer Dependency Map, and I'll point out that at this
year's AACR meeting, this was the project that won the Team
Science Award and recognized. But we back up a little bit
over a decade ago when I was talking to Bill Hahn and Levi
Garraway, Bill talking about Project Achilles, finding
cell or genes that are essential in cancer.
We jumped in and became interested in going forward in time.
This is the project that now results, the Cancer Dependency Map.
But essentially, taking now well over 1,000 cancer
cell lines and systematically asking what genes, when
turned off, will specifically kill cancers in a
setting. So we've loaded in now over 20 rhabdoid tumor
cell lines, and essentially the other 1,000 cancers become your
control. And so we ask what genes, when turned off,
specifically kill rhabdoid tumor cells and also doing this in
chemical space as well. So just want to highlight a
project led by a star graduate student, Hayden Malone,
with collaboration from Jackie Meyers, computational biologist
in the lab who's phenomenal, and Emma Gruss, who's a research technician.
And when I put all of this together, it was unpublished, but it now actually just
came out last week.
And so what we did then was take these thousand cancer cell lines.
At this point, we had 15 rhabdoid tumor cell lines, genome-wide
CRISPR screening, select over
21 days. And what we find is that this gene,
FIP, is sort of like 10 to the negative eighth power here
shown of specificity for becoming specifically dependent.
And you see the power of the functional genomic screens in many ways as you're
seeing these P values, Q values actually, that are coming out.
We're really getting specific insights into what's going on.
Hayden went on to show that it was not only rhabdoid tumors that have this
specific dependence, but there's a type of ovarian cancer caused by
mutation of a different SWI/SNF subunit, known as BRG1 or
SMARCA4. These are small cell carcinomas of the
ovary hypercalcemic type, also very
strongly dependent.
So then Hayden went on to take a look more in-depth map, and what we found
was, I think, interesting, that things that had damaging
mutations in SMARCA4 or SMARCB1 created a
dependency, whereas mutations in other subunits of the
SWI/SNF complex here, PBRM1 and ARID1A, did
not create the same dependency. And so what's
going on there? Why certain subunits of the complex are causing this
particular dependency and not others?
And so, as Hayden has done work and looked at this, I want to just
distill what we think is the key point.
So SMARCB1 is present in two of the three families, and
actually the two dominant families, that less is known about NCBAF or
GBAF, but it has the least strong role in
transcriptional activation. And so one is essentially
inactivating broadly SWI/SNF function by hitting
SMARCB1.In the
scoots, which inactivate SMARCA4, now you're picking up
disruption of all three complexes.
So both of these mutations, very strong effects on switch and if
function. In contrast, the ARID1A mutation, which
is quite frequent in cancer, only affects the cBAF family, and in
fact, only a subset of cBAF because other cBAFs have
ARID1B. And if we look at PBRM1, this
only affects the pBAF family. And so what we're
really beginning to see is that this switch and if
complex plays key roles in transcriptional activation,
but the different subunits are having different functions, having different effects
on which particular transcription factors are involved, which
pathways are altered. And so with this genetic screening, we're now
beginning to actually dissect what the functions
of different subunits and where they contribute.
Okay, so what is this protein that we're calling FYP?
It has two bromodomains, so very interesting there when one
begins to think about chemical targeting.
A Tudor domain. It is known to bind to
nucleosomes and be able to recruit a CRL4 E3 ubiquitin
ligase complex, and had been shown capable of
degrading a couple of chromatin-bound
proteins during DNA replication, which is when it had
primarily been implicated. It's been overexpressed in a
couple of cancer types, which has then led companies to
begin thinking about can they therapeutically target it.
And it has a fairly distinct bromodomain, which opens the doors to
potentially getting chemical matter that will bind FYP, but not other
bromodomains.
So we then asked, might this thing have a role in transcription?
It's been implicated in replication.
And so what Hayden did was begin looking at ChIP-seq, and what we
find is that FYP here is really
bound at promoters, where there's H3K4 trimethyl, active
promoters, K27 acetyl, a K14 acetyl,
a depletion of K4 monomethyl, and largely at
active promoters. There's no polycomb-mediated writing here,
although you do see that there is some sites of overlap
between silent promoters and FYP binding.
When she took a look at what happens by inactivating FYP here
with siRNAs against FYP, what we see is that the activating
histone marks that are associated with transcriptional activation are
now substantially impaired, with K14 acetyl, K27 acetyl,
and H4K12 acetyl all going
down with FYP loss, with K14 acetyl being the
most strongly affected across three different rhabdoid tumor cell lines.
So what's it doing? Is the E3 important in
this activity? And so, to my surprise, when
Hayden took a look at what the effect is of knocking down
FYP, the other subunits of the
CRL4 complex no longer bind to chromatin.
So this complex interacts with multiple E3 adapter
proteins, and so I was surprised that hitting one of
them, FYP, was going to actually be sufficient to evict it
from chromatin.
And then this is just that data shown in ChIP-seq space with
under si control.
Now looking at the DDB1 subunit and with knocking down FYP,
we see substantial impairment of binding
there.
So FYP contributes now to the active transcriptional
state and is recruiting the E3 ligase.
So that opens the question of, okay, well, what's the target
then, and what's going on?
So Hayden did a really nice job of doing IP mass spec.
This is now in G401 rhabdoid tumor cells,
and did the spectral counts, found all of these proteins,
which are components of the Nurd repressor
complex.
So then she went ahead to directly test in vitro, can
FYP
ubiquitinate the subunits of this complex?
And here, looking at CHD4, the most strongly affected,
very strongly the case that it gets polyubiquitinated
directly by FYP when provided with
E1 and E2s. So, also seeing the MTA2
being affected, and to a lesser extent, other subunits of the Nurd
repressor complex.
So she then took a look at what are the consequences of
targeting FYP upon Nurd, and now we're looking at the
CHD4 subunit of the Nurd complex. And so when
she knocks down FYP, we see increased
binding of CHD4. And interestingly,
the increase in CHD4 only occurs at the sites
where Nurd is co-bound with FYP. And if we look at where the Nurd
complex is bound without FYP, no change
in binding there. So a substantial rise
in Nurd repressor complex.
That's in ChIP-seq space shown here.
When she degrades FYP, now the DDB1 subunit of
CRL4 is gone.
We then see the accumulation of the Nurd complex because it's no
longer being effectively degraded.
Nurd, one of the functions is a histone deacetylase,
and in fact, we now then see the corresponding drop in
H4 acetylation where Nurd binding has
increased.So we then
asked,
so why is Nurd then and FIP becoming a
dependency, particularly when we manipulate when SMARCB1 is
lost?
She took a look here at now SMARCA4 that have high
levels of SMARCA2, the other ATPase subunit.
No particularly strong dependency there, but in the cancers that have
damaging mutations of SMARCA4 and low levels of SMARCA2, which
include SCOOT and others, we have the dependency.
So now she wanted to ask, because there are degraders
in chemical space, in clinical trials of switch NIF subunits,
SMARCA2, SMARCA4, and you see when you add the drug here, you completely
wipe out these proteins.
Does that affect FIP's function in degrading Nurd?
And so the first thing we look at, this is the Nurd subunits.
The addition of the switch NIF degrader itself really has no effect on the
abundance of Nurd complexes. Adding FIP, this is
ectopic expression of FIP in 293T cells,
also doesn't really affect Nurd levels.
But if you use the drug with FIP, now
it activates the ability of FIP to degrade.
And so it is loss of function of the switch NIF
complex that is then stimulating
FIP in terms of degrading Nurd.
Does this matter in vivo? And so now Hayden took
cell lines, degraded FIP, put them into mice, and so
here is without FIP degradation, and here is with
FIP degradation. So we're getting a significant prolongation.
We take a look at that and say, "Okay, that's significant, but
they're coming back. What's going on?" And these were pooled
cells, and so what we see, while FIP was gone in the beginning, the
tumors that come out, FIP is now being rescued and coming back.
And so we're essentially getting selection for cells that have
regained the ability to express FIP are the ones that are growing.
When we look in vivo in cult cells culture, as long as we can
keep FIP gone, the cells will not proliferate.
So the model then becomes in wild type enhancers, switch
NIF complex and Nurd complex are doing battle for activation and
silencing, same as promoters. That when SMARCB1 is
lost, this really dramatically impairs function
of enhancers, Nurd complex.
They're lost. The Nurd complex really relocalizes now
strongly to promoters trying to silence.
But here, FIP inactivates the Nurd complex
to enable cells to continue transcription.
And then if we target FIP, we now get a
loss of transcription. And so essentially the targets that are
normally activated by switch NIF in a cell when
SMARCB1 is lost, that would normally be
lethal to a cell. But FIP is there enough to rescue
transcription to make sure it's not a fatal event.
You pull FIP out, Nurd takes over, and now essentially a transcriptional
collapse. So I think I won't hit these
points. I just went through them verbally on the model system.
But one of the things that has been fascinating as we have gone into the
functional genomic screening space is how much
information has emerged.
And so we first found EZH2, and we actually found EZH2
from a genetic screen. It was just one that was done in Drosophila in the 1990s by
other labs, and we became interested in this when we first started working on
switch NIF. Might EZH2
be relevant?
Yes, it was, and now that we are doing the genomic screens, that pops
as well. We then found a specific
paralog dependency between SMARCA2 and SMARCA4 that
we reported, and as I'll point out, that's gone to the clinic,
as well as a paralog dependency between ARID1A and
ARID1B. Then Scott's lab, our lab,
and Segal's lab all found the existence of this third family.
Up until this point in the genetic screens, we only knew of the two families of the
switch NIF complex, the cBAF and pBAF.
Through the genetic screening, we learned about this third family that then becomes
essential when SMARCB1 is inactivated.
Priya in the lab then led the project finding
PHF6 as a specific dependency and in fact finding that it
cooperates with the switch NIF complex and transcriptional activation.
We then find NSD1 works to oppose polycomb
activity. We find DCAF5 that I told you about.
Now comes Hayden finding the dependency on FIP,
and we've got several others that are going along.
And so it's been really powerful in terms
of alerting us to proteins that we had
no idea were there that would turn out to be absolutely
critical for the function of these complexes.
And then as we think about it, it's also turning out to be
illuminating in terms of therapy.
And so these are the papers from the lab that have then implicated
things that we think are therapeutically actionable,
some of which have gone forward. So following our work,
there was FDA approval for tazemetostat, an EZH2
inhibitor in
cancers that had loss of INI1 or SMARCB1.
And now this is a table that we put together, that Hayden put
together a couple of years ago in terms of a review.
These are all of the targets that have come out of the functional genomic
screening, and you'll notice on the right just how many of these
now have advanced all the way to clinical trials
and therapy and excited. For instance, the SMARCA2,
SMARCA4 that I told you about, now quite a few
clinical trials going forward here.
The ARID1A, ARID1B, much more difficult, but Foghorn now
I understand has a degrader for ARID1B, and so a number of
these things are going forward, and now FIP can be added to the list of
things that one can think about in terms of therapeutically targeting.
So I really wanted to again highlight the
role of Hayden, the graduate student, who's now going to be joining Jerry Crabtree
in Nathaniel Grey's lab at Stanford for a postdoc. Jackie Meyers.
Phenomenal collaborations along the way from others who have
done the work. And funding is shown here, and I'll happy to take
questions.Yeah.
Hi, Charles. Nice talk. My question is regarding
your
discovery that there is E3 ubiquitin-mediated
degradation on the chromatin. But there's a lot of evidences which shows that when
you import a ligase at those loci, there is
often mono-ubiquitination-mediated regulation of transcription rather than
degradation. Did you get a chance to look at that aspect of PHIP?
Yeah. I think this is such an important question.
Particularly as we're looking at multiple different E3s.
I think it's very clear, just as you say, that mono-ubiquitin can have
effects. So we do not have full, clean answers on this.
We very much have seen the degradation of the Nurd complex,
but are also interested, are there things outside of degradation that
are affecting signaling? Super important question, but I don't have definitive
answers for you yet.
Charlie, excellent talk.
Did you try in the experiment where you inhibit PHIP and you saw Nurd complex
increasing, did you try an inducible system to bring back PHIP and
see if you can now remove which is dominant there?
If you bring back PHIP, can you
take out Nurd from repressing?
Deleting PHIP, seeing
Nurd come, and then rescuing that to directly then see if we can-
Reverse the Nurd repression.
Yeah. We have not done directly that experiment.
I think it's an interesting one to do to make genetic proof of
what's happening there. We have not done that one.
Hi, thanks for your talk. I was curious if you looked into whether there
are post-translational modifications on PHIP that enable its association with
the broader complex during transcription.
Yeah. I think also a really interesting and important
question. We haven't directly done that.
We have looked at the post-translational modifications on the SwitchNif complex,
and there's an enormous number of them.
And so we have not, particularly on subunits like SMARCC1.
So we have not directly looked at what's going on there,
but I wouldn't at all be surprised if that's playing a key role
in locking these associations and facilitation.
Just a complex thing that we need to take a look at.
All right. Thanks, everyone. And thank you to the speakers for a great
session.